bây giờ tạm như trắng, tổng thống mấy đôn nân trắng cho biết ông đã trở phép của tình báo trường
mấy CIA, tiến hành hát chính sĩ mặt tại Vinodzilla. Chào mất cảnh Washington
gia tăng rất đáng lẹp lên chính quyền tổng thống Nicolas Maduro, Khá Tên New York Times,
chỉ tìm mặt đây mở dọng thầm quyền của CIA tại khu vực cả li bệnh năm trong
chính lượng, nhằm thấy đổi cuộc diện chính chiếm ở Vinodzilla. Tổng thống
trắng trơn sang, huy định đưa ra về tình trạng ZCOA và Buôn Bản Mà Tối,
sau không được ra bằng chính cuộc thay. Nhà trắng từ chỗ bình luận chi tiết về những hành động cuộc thay,
Mà CIA được phép thực hiện. Vìa cán ơn các lấy nạn đây lành đi cán thiệt chẳng và công định đối bộ
đi phạm lột pháp cuộc tế, đồng tự tuyên bố sẽ đưa vụ việc ra hội đồng bóa lên được quốc,
dưới qua xác trường sang đồng thấy này đánh giống sự trở lại của mua mình ngoại xấu